Did Muhammad exist? A huge controversy
has arisen over this question just in
recent weeks?
And many people think that the whole
idea is either trivial or absurd.
And yet there are enough strange aspects
of the question that I myself have
written two books about the subject. My
dear friend Iban Warak has written even
more than that. Recently he appeared on
Winston Marshall's show and he said this
about the issue.
>> All our knowledge of
the lives of Muhammad the prophet of
Islam are based on
literary evidence which some of it dates
more than 300 years after his supposed
death.
So there are no surviving extent you
know um
documents
which are contrainous with with
>> with the Quran
>> including in another part of the
interview
Winston Marshall asks Iban Warak about
Ed Hussein who is an Islamic apologist
in the UK and who dismissed questions
questions about pedophilia in Islam
emanating from Muhammad's example in his
marriage to Aisha who he consummated his
marriage with or raped when he was 54
and she was nine according to the
Islamic sources. Hussein dismissed all
this by saying well those sources are
late and Iben Warak said this
>> our knowledge of
all all the uh his wives what he did and
so on but contained in the hadith
the hadith were written over 300 years
after his death. So how can and then
then
but you see somebody like Hussein who
will argue about the details of his life
but when it becomes inconvenient he will
bring up the idea of lateness of the
sources but if they if they're late
they're late for everything none not a
single
aspect of his life is is authentic.
So this has become a massive controversy
quite recently even though the question
has been around for years and there have
been numerous debates and videos about
various aspects of the issue. You may
have seen some of them. One unfortunate
aspect of this is that there is a
growing tendency among some people to
treat the entire question with scorn and
ridicule. acting as if it's a crazy idea
that emanates from one person who's
going off halfcocked, characterizing
those who believe in it as a cult,
belittling them with nicknames that are
meant to mock the whole idea and mock
the people who raised it and the like.
Now, this is a shame because it is a
legitimate question and an important
one. One curious aspect of these
controversies has been the charge that
even to suggest that Muhammad may not
have existed is detrimental for
Christians who were in discussion with
Muslims as it undermines the moral
critique of Muhammad's life. Now,
there's no reason why this has to be
true. Muslims believe in and imitate
Muhammad as he's depicted in the Islamic
sources, and so the moral critique is
valid and necessary. The question of
whether those sources have any
historical value, however, is a separate
one and likewise valid.
Some say it's counterproductive for
Christian apologetics, but there's no
reason why that needs to be so either.
And also, the validity of any line of
inquiry is not actually based on how
useful the line of inquiry is for one
purpose or another. It's based on to
what extent the question illuminates the
truth and let the chips fall where they
may. So discussions of the historicity
of Muhammad and the origins of Islam are
valid and necessary. They do not emanate
from a cult. They are not the province
of one man's imagination and they are
neither silly nor stupid. What is
counterproductive and unnecessary in the
all too human temptation to read people
out of this or that group of the
movement based on their views on this
issue is that the evidence for the
historicity of Muhammad is just about as
strong or weak depending on your point
of view as the evidence against. And so
people of goodwill can and do disagree
about the value of that evidence.
Now, beware of the temptation to think
that you know all about an issue or have
heard all the arguments involved in
justifying a particular point of view
because you've watched a few videos or
debates. It is simply not possible to
present all the arguments for or against
Muhammad's existence in a video or
debate or even a series thereof.
Consider the difference between a book
and a movie. A book is going to have
more detail, more nuance, more
explanation, more subplots, more
character development, and more. Unless
the book itself comes after the movie
and is a novelization of the movie. If
you really want to know a story well
that exists in both forms, you can't
just watch the movie. Also the question
of who won a debate is not the same as
the question of whether the argument on
one side or another is stronger. Someone
might be a good debater, someone might
be a bad debater or someone might be
having a good day or a bad day or may
not have marshaled all the most the
strongest arguments in favor of a
particular position. Debates I find
generally they might be entertaining but
they generate more heat than light. If
you really want to know about the
reasons for challenging Muhammad's
historicity, you're going to have to
find the information in books. Here are
a few good ones. In the first place, you
have
somewhere here.
You have the book did Muhammad exist
that I wrote in 2010 and then revised
and expanded a few years ago and that
lays out the basic case and uh most of
the principal reasons for why this is a
legitimate and important question. Then
I followed that up last year with a book
called Muhammad, a critical biography,
which is exactly that, a critical
evaluation of the accounts of Muhammad's
life from the earliest Islamic sources,
evaluating them from a historical
standpoint and uh questioning their
historical reliability on the basis of
largely internal evidence,
contradictions with other versions of
the story and the like. But of course I
am by no means the only person who has
written books about this issue. One
excellent book on it is crossroads to
Islam, the origins of the Arab religion
and the Arab state by Yehuda Navo and
Judith Corin. Another is the
groundbreaking work that many have
dismissed without due consideration
Kristoff Luxembourg's the seroic reading
of the Quran. Luxembourg notes that the
earliest manuscripts of the Quran
contain no diiocritical marks. If you're
familiar with the Arabic alphabet, you
know that many of the letters are
identical one to another. 16 of the 22
letters have another letter that looks
just like it except for the dots that
are above and below it. And the only way
you can tell whether it's one letter or
another is by those diioritical marks.
So Luxembourg noted that since the
earliest extant Qurans manuscripts have
no diiocritical marks at all that
there's actually quite a lot of
variability in what the text is actually
saying and he contends that there's an
Aramaic substratum to quite a lot of it.
Uh people who
put a great value in the fact that there
are early extent Quran manuscripts are
often not only exaggerating the age of
those manuscripts but also
overestimating the importance of them as
actual Quranic manuscripts.
uh to have a manus a fragment of the
Quran that purports to be from the
middle of the 7th century is not the
same as having a copy of the
standardized edition from today which
was only standardized in the early 20th
century. Uh the with lack of the diet
critical marks creates quite a lot of
variability and Luxembourg's book is
quite complicated but well worth the
effort. Also, Gunter Luling, a challenge
to Islam for reformation where he also
finds various textual substrada within
the Quran in uh passages that are
obscure, scrambled, odd, ambiguous, and
he looks at the text in a different way,
noting the absence of the diiocritical
marks and coming up with some quite
compelling
readings. Then there is Iban Warak who
we saw a few moments ago and he's
written many important books on this the
origins of the Quran, the quest for the
historical Muhammad. These are and the
these others are essay collections from
some of the great pioneering scholars of
this issue. You might be interested to
know that there were scholars who were
working in this area in the 19th and
20th century. Got very little attention
for it. Uh but nonetheless, this is as I
say not something invented by some
YouTuber that you may not like because
he said something wrong one day. Uh
Christmas in the Quran is another one
from Ibenara. Quite lengthy, but a
fascinating inquiry. the the title
refers to an essay within it that shows,
I think, definitively that the latter
part of Surah 5 in the Quran was
originally a reference to uh Christmas
and to the Eucharist. And so uh you can
check that out. And then there's my own
book, The Critical Quran, which uh takes
many of these findings and puts them in
the particular context of the passages
themselves in a new and clear
translation.
So in any case uh if if you see one
video or a couple of videos and you
think this whole idea is now stupid and
to be ridiculed and rejected uh it seems
clear that very many people who are
preeminent scholars in this field and by
no means to be rejected out of hand have
taken it quite a bit more seriously and
that might be something worth bearing in
mind. Another point, some people say
that the long gap between the time that
Muhammad supposedly lived and the
sources about his life is simply
something standard in history and that
there are similar long gaps involved in
the lives of numerous important figures
in history. This is actually false. Uh,
one of these people who is often invoked
in this regard is Alexander the Great
because there's a similarity between him
and Muhammad. Uh, not just that they
were both warriors who led armies
according to the sources, but that
Alexander the Great uh, the lives and
the stories about him, they generally
come from about 200 years after his
death and the period thereafter. And so
that's pretty much the same as in the
case of Muhammad.
uh in fact remarkably similar in
Alexander's case however and very much
unlike the situation of Muhammad there
are numerous inscriptions mentioning him
during his lifetime in 330 BC which is 7
years before he died in the city of
Prien there is an inscription
commemorating Alexander's dedication of
the temple of Athena polio in that city
and it says very simply king Alexander
dedicated this temple to Athena polas.
Uh unlike the sparse mentions of
Muhammad that date from the first 60
years after his supposed date of death,
neither this inscription nor any of the
others about Alexander that date from
during his lifetime get the key details
of his life drastically wrong. Whereas
all the accounts that we have of
Muhammad from the 7th century do not
correspond to the standard Islamic story
about what he said and did. So you got
to, you know, nobody got it right.
Nobody even got close. You got to
wonder. Uh take also Julius Caesar. We
have his own commentaries on the gic war
and on the civil war in the Roman
Republic and then empire. We also have
accounts of him from his contemporaries
Marcus Tia Cicero and Solast. For
Muhammad, we have none of his writings
and no accounts from any of his
contemporaries except for material that
first appears in 9th century documents.
And so that's 200 years after his death.
And there we are again. Some people will
say, "Well, we do have the Quran." But
the Quran actually does not give us any
details about the life of Muhammad. It
doesn't even mention him aside from four
uh mentions, none of which have any
biographical data in them. And the many
references to the messenger and to the
prophet, they don't contain any
biographical information either. And so
you can find discussion of that once
again in the critical Quran. So I would
say uh beware of the temptation to get
stampeded here and to think that you
know all about an issue because of a few
debates that you may have seen. Next
time that you're tempted to watch a
video about one side or another of the
Muhammad controversy, enjoy the video.
But after that, pick up a book and read
about this issue. I can tell you from
personal experience, it's fascinating
and the study of it is richly rewarding.
You will not regret the time that you
spend on it. Thank you.